alrighty and welcome back to the show
countdown to kickoff to super bowl 55
there are a ton of bets you can make
with either patrick mahomes or tom brady
but ron futrell now joins us with a prop
bit
that doesn't involve either of those two
players ron yes indeed chris super bowl
proposition bets
are some of the most interesting ones
out there who scores the first touchdown
how many sacks in the game well there's
one you can get out of the way
well way before kickoff two tails is the
call
tails is a call joe do us a favor tails
is the call
it is tails carolina wins a toss yes the
coin toss is still one of the favorite
super bowl bets
it's funny about the the coin toss which
is one of the more popular bets on the
board
as we see so many people like to bet it
and it's always very
fun to be in the sports book when you do
have that coin toss the odds are
slightly less than even for both sides
because the sports books have to make
their cut
by the way through 54 super bowls tails
has hit 29 times heads 25.
i remember one guy came in he had 30 000
and he was going to bet the game and he
couldn't figure out what to do so he
decided
you know i'm just going to bet the coin
toss and get it over with so we bet
heads
thirty thousand on heads bang winner
enjoy the rest of the day
yes who needs the chiefs or bucks when
you have a coin to toss
i'm ron futrell eight news now and it is
ahead new england you've won the toss
there you go by the way 60 of the bets
right now
on kansas city to win the coin toss now
that's a different bet
than heads or tails it's a separate bet
you can make on which team will
win the coin toss there's the perception
out there chris that kansas city is just
lucky okay in 2018 they started the
season
by winning nine consecutive coin tosses
all right well
i'm still going bucks and heads for the
game we'll see what happens hunt
auctions at nfl auction once again
collaborating with the super bowl 55
to host the 13th annual super bowl live
auction saturday in tampa the